okay okay beat beat I'm just glad we're
still alive
sometimes video games confuse the hell
out of me how is it that a game is full
of diverse objectives and activities as
something like assasin creed black flag
could bore me after several honest
attempts to love it and conversely how
is it that a largely incomplete game in
a genre that hasn't seen mainstream
success in years could entranced me so
deeply ever since playing a very early
preview build of armikrog these are the
questions that have been plaguing my
thoughts what is it about this little
claymation based point-and-click
adventure that can make me feel
excitement and intrigue more
successfully than a multi-million dollar
project in a beloved series of games
well in spite of the placeholder visuals
temporary voice acting lack of music or
ambient audio in the incomplete nature
of the whole project armikrog is already
a game with heart what it lacks in
triple-a polish it makes up for in
spades with weird understated humor head
scratching puzzles environmental
atmosphere and a wealth of character as
I wandered the world of armikrog I felt
the alien mess of it all
nothing was labeled or explained I
wasn't sure where the world I was going
to explore began or ended nothing was
telling me where to go or what my role
was in all of this I simply was allowed
to feel out the world as I saw fit until
I began to piece together the earliest
elements of the first puzzles and this
hands-off approach is something that I
often longed for and more curated gaming
experiences to harken back to the
Assassin's Creed example sure the
opening of Black Flag gives you
background on who you are in the world
and it leaves you with context for your
adventure but imagine for a moment if
you were simply tossed into the deep end
with no texts no cutscenes no dialogue
the impression the world had on you
would be entirely different you wouldn't
be fed any preformed ideas about what
this place is or why you inhabit it as
it exists being fed so much expository
information right off the bat is like
opening the Hobbit to find a list of all
the characters with illustrations of
what they definitively look like you
would never have the chance to allow
your imagination to get creative with
the diegetic universe you're engaging
it's almost as if the measures taken to
ensure that the player gets the intended
experience is actually preventing the
player from finding their own unique
subjective experience which in my
opinion is much more important because
puzzles are such a central element to
any point-and-click adventure I must
also make note here of the strength of
the puzzles in this early section of the
game one involved entering a passcode of
sorts with no text to najin and
direction the solution spoiler alert
comes through a few sections of the game
where beak beak you're talking alien dog
companion must fend her off on his own
giving you access to a black and white
dog vision of sorts that can reveal
hidden clues and better yet I never even
found all three necessary clues after
finding the first two I tried to every
possible candidate for the third clue
until the door just popped open hell I
don't even know if there is a third clue
hidden somewhere and the fact that I may
never know excites me there's an element
of mystery in the absence of concrete
explanation that makes this feel less
like a linear tour of puzzles stitched
together with narrative and more like an
indifferent world filled with obstacles
through which I'm progressing absorption
at this level is incredibly important to
me in any game experience as soon as I
begin to lose that trance of novelty
that comes from being lost in the games
world my mind begins to decide the
mechanics of the gameplay to a degree
that I'm no longer entranced at this
point quest missions and objectives
simply become chores instead of fun
activities it doesn't matter if your
world is littered with nine thousand
procedurally generated side quests if I
don't care about my role in them or the
world that they impact armikrog may not
even be a complete game but I know for a
fact that I'll be playing it upon
release because it's a game of heart and
a real creative force behind it because
the game is incomplete and therefore so
reliant on these characters in this
world to carry it there's a
figure-ground shift in my typical
approach to games my relentlessly
analytical mind was no longer looking to
game the system or figure out the
mechanism behind the curtain as it so
frequently does with other games instead
I was simply immersed and invested and
that's why we love games in the first
place isn't it not because they
force-feed us excitement but because
they create a medium through which we
can find it for ourselves